[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
qui sera essentiellement consacré à la
place de l'écologie dans l'élection
présidentielle ce sont des questions
essentielles puisque conditionne
l'avenir de la planète l'avenir aussi de
nos vies dans les 30-50 ans qui viennent
et puis peut-être aussi des questions
philosophiques on le verra est ce que
dans la primaire il ya deux philosophies
de l'écologie qui s'opposent pour en
parler island sonné bonjour vous êtes la
présidente du groupe e élevé au conseil
régional
c'est d'ailleurs la tête de liste dans
les yvelines à de 2,7
et génération et oui c'est parce qu'il
sait le pôle écologiste absolument
avec nous alors
salomé tdu bonjour bonjour vous êtes
alors je suis ravi de vous avez vous
êtes étudiante à sciences po
saint-germain exacte et vous nous direz
justement peut-être que pour les jeunes
c'est important peut-être d'écologie oui
on est content j'ai
dû dire que beauregard bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes vous êtes conseiller
municipal a
pour cela vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'énergie vous êtes vous a été ou ses
voies vous a été
conseillé d'edith cresson quand elle
était premier ministre sur les questions
d'énergie notamment et vous avez
participé aussi à ce numéro spécial de
marianne sur l'écologie et vous le dire
tout de suite cette double nucléaire
j'expliquerai pourquoi pas pour le choix
et je sens venir sébacées le vide un
élève de 7 grâce puisque huit là bas des
arbres
si vous êtes éditeur nous sommes créé un
séisme de forêts bien fin je ne suis
plus que les termes raisonnée voilà non
non donc voilà et en plus on fait des
livres de poche c'est plus petit le
paquet les villes de poche non il ya des
deux dernières apparitions dont du père
voilà deux ans mathis ferrero l'histoire
passionnante entre l'espagne la france
et sur l'histoire un peu de pied noir
qui se retrouvent enfin d'office de
pieds-noirs
et amusant et passionnant et puis mais
emmanuel vers l'est en cavale voilà le
manuel valls à lui c'est un ancien
commandant de police soit qu'ils
imposent à retraite ac s'est récemment
et qui écrit les d'excellents romans
policiers il est assez original qui se
passe dans une zad dans la forêt tout
c'est un assez peu de vivres pour
l'instant
c'est vraiment très très très original
et puis palpitant et manuel valls en
cavale peut-être avant de concéder un
mot sur ce qui se passe en allemagne
les verts étaient très favoris un moment
là ils sont 14% alors ils vont se
retrouver ce probablement au centre de
la coédition est au centre des
collections est ce que ce serait avec
les csp des deux cd ou mais comment vous
expliquez vous faut le un peu la chute
disco à un moment c'était le premier
parti allemand mais la chute moi je
crois que la grande difficulté que nous
avons nous les écologistes c'est
d'essayer de faire comprendre que le
message qu'on essaie de faire passer que
l'urgence climatique va effectivement
entraîner un changement de société et
que face à la réalité en fait
humainement voilà les personnes sont
inquiètes et préfère finalement
la solution de facilité je dirais parce
que parce que les décisions qui doivent
être prises sont sont importantes et evo
vont entraîner forcément des changements
mis donc moi je crois réellement que il
est difficile de faire passer des
messages est temps que l'ensemble de la
classe politique ne portera pas un
message de réalité et bien nous aurons
effectivement au dernier moment
toujours des réticences parce que on
nous fait croire qu'on peut continuer
comme avant que la technologie quels
progrès nous permettra de vivre encore
mieux mais encore faut-il savoir que ce
que veut dire encore mieux est ce que
c'est la crise sanitaire et du
confinement est ce que c'est mieux vous
avez déjà des questions qui vont re qui
vont nourrir cette émission une autre
question quand même sur l'allemagne et
vous pouvez intervenir évidemment alors
il est question énergétique de
l'allemagne qui
voulait parler de tout de suite en 97 ou
souvenez la gauche a le pouvoir avec les
écologistes dominique voynet ministre
l'année carraz est une année très noir
pour le nucléaire comme vous le savez
puisque ça a été le début de l'arrêt de
beaucoup d'aspects nucléaire est
derrière l'allemagne a aussi ses
élections et les verts ont une
importance énorme et vous souvenez que
l'allemagne abandonné la france sur le
pea donc donc si vous voulez ce qui se
passe en ce moment est très important
pour nous aussi de ce point de vue là on
par rapport au débat énergétique et au
débat nucléaire quel que soit le camp
dans laquelle l'allemagne
et l'allemagne d'avant le nuclaire
l'allemagne si mince avance et nucléaire
schoder abandon du nucléaire et puis au
moins de fukushima connaît bien
l'histoire madame merkel aussi donc
c'est un sujet important pour la france
de regarder ce qui va se passer dans
cette coalition et les décisions qui
vont être prises vraiment que c'est
important
à la séance aller jusqu'au fond du débat
mais l abandonner le nucléaire est
évidemment l'énergie c'est notamment le
charbon enfin qu'il est surtout pour le
gaz russe qui vous donnent rendez vous
enfin au fond il ya eu un tropisme très
fort il a toujours des remises très fort
de l'allemagne par rapport à la russie
pour son énergie nostry main stream 2 le
gaz est donc elle a choisi gaz enfin
c'est clair tout en faisant une alliance
géopolitique mais bon c'est aux dépens
de la france à ce moment là
et l'autre question peut-être de
relations avec l'allemagne en relation
avec l'allemagne on voit là il ya des
négociations qui vont avoir lieu qui
vont prendre d'ailleurs un certain temps
peut-être un mois on pourrait établir
une coalition qui soit solide
c'est vrai que
nous avons nous un système
présidentielle où il n'y a que deux
candidats au deuxième tour ça marchait
bien quand la france quand le lui avais
la gauche la droite est ce
qu'aujourd'hui où il ya au fond cinq ou
six force politique importante en france
est ce que c'est un système qui
correspond encore à nos besoins
démocratique centaine en france oui
c'est à dire passer sa présidentielle
notamment fin non non il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à le réformer on voit bien
qu'il ya toujours l'incarnation de
l'homme et d'une ancienne femme la femme
et l'homme
sait pas quand même si on risque d'avoir
un retour de lomé mais n'ont montré très
diverses mais dès jeudi je ferai une
bonne chancelière
je crois aujourd'hui qu'il ya il ya
vraiment nécessité a cessé en fait cessé
c'est ce bipartisme droite gauche qui
fait lorsque il ya une alternance claque
on va absolument casser ce qui a été
fait pour pouvoir faire pour pouvoir
faire autre chose moi j'ai vécu la
région ile-de-france 59e production a
perdu la région et valérie pêle-mêle
c'est arrivé que la condal casser toutes
les politiques publiques pour en faire
soit des 6000 soit des différentes mais
on voit bien qu'il ya pas de continuité
dans l'action politique or aujourd'hui
l'urgence climatique ne demande à
réfléchir sur le temps long et donc on
ne peut plus à mon sens
casser pour que politiquement on puisse
exister sur sur la scène antennes de
communication alors que il ya vraiment
des objectifs des priorités qu'on doit
globalement tous ensemble ça fixée et
puis c'est vrai qu'avec eux et c'est
vrai qu'on a six forces politico jacques
bigot faial il ya la gauche qui est des
écolos il ya le
centrisme il ya la droite républicaine
et l'extrême droite c'est plus on n'est
plus un combat bipolaire est-ce que
c'est demont à des institutions qui
correspondent à ça c'est une question
qu'on pourrait se poser quand même
moi je trouve que le pire il n'ya pas
tant de force politique importante que
ça et puisque ce que disait madame de
droite gauche là c'est pas de radio
c'était macron canton l'extrême droite
au deuxième tour ça me paraît pas
aberrant et bon là pour l'instant parler
de la gauche verts c'est quand même une
minuscule ici mme
vallée les écologistes on verra si c'est
jamais sandrine rousseau est candidate
ça ça ne se pense pas que ce sera un
parti très important pour l'élection
présidentielle voilà donc il faut raison
garder vous lire normal il ya un
candidat centre-droit emmanuel macron
puis après on verra peut-être que la
droite n'a pas non mais on n'est plus
dans le vivaldi je disais est ce que
c'est ce qu'on a un système politique
qui correspond à ce qu'ils puissent qui
marchait quand on déteste dans une sorte
de huit partisans de grande force quoi
fonctionne parce qu'il y aura toujours
les questions qui pourraient se poser
autour et les législatives qui suivent
et qui permette de rééquilibrer son plus
tôt c'est plutôt 5 vincent couronne sur
ces questions
oui moi ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que au fond de ce que de ce que
j'entends à vous écouter c'est que en
fait le la protection d'environnement
l'écologie c'est devenu un sujet
transversal dents au sein des partis
politiques dire qu'il n'est plus
attribué ou la propriété d'un seul parti
et ce à quoi sont dépensés en fait c'est
à l'évolution de l'état de droit dire
que qu'est-ce qui fait dans notre
société consensus à gauche à droite y
compris l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite et l'extrême droite en passant
par le centre est et que nous que nous
nous engageons tous en fête à respecter
quelle est la voie sur laquelle nous
nous voulons tous aller alors évidemment
un de ces consensus et on ne fait pas de
traite des êtres humains pas d'esclaves
âge on vit en démocratie a priori ça
fait encore consensus et aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que ben le dérèglement
climatique c'est aussi un de ses poids
désormais qui s'est suffisamment
solidifier dans notre société
suffisamment ancrées et suffisamment qui
fait suffisamment consensus pour que eh
bien ça ça fasse partie désormais des
biens de notre état de droit notre droit
est modifiée par par le dérèglement
climatique et par la lutte contre ce
dérèglement climatique eh bien il ya
fort à parier que
un peu comme le féminisme aujourd'hui
même aujourd'hui marine le pen se
réclament féministe je veux dire ce sont
des choses ont failli france utilement
consensus dans la société pour que
probablement en fait demain nos
constitutions le l'union européenne et
peut-être même la société internationale
soient prêtes peut-être est mûr pour
avancer sur ces questions là salomé
treillis justement les jeunes on voit
bien il ya parlé ici beaucoup de monde
d'engagement déjà dans la politique mais
il ya beaucoup d'engagement associatif
et notamment notamment dans le domaine
écologique vous sentez ça oui on l'a vu
dans les nombreuses manifestations
notamment
il ya deux ans pour le climat de
nombreux jeunes s'étaient mobilisés tant
à sciences po que dans mon entourage
pour justement le climat est en faveur
du changement
après pour revenir aux propos de général
et de vingt cinq mois il pourrait être
intéressant d'avoir plus une tête une
écologie de fond et une présidence tout
en présidant écologistes en 2022
pourrait justement permettre de faire
évoluer
plus en profondeur les choses sur la
question de la transition écologique
en comparaison ajustements la droite ou
la gauche qui pourrait juste place et
l'écologie en partie dans leurs
programmes sans en faire une de leurs
priorités de leur contexte et bien
justement on va aborder cette question
de la primaire et écologique sa voix à
ce que ça a été une réussite ou un échec
c'est le premier thème de cette émission
j'appuie là-dessus sévère
[Musique]
alors 2e tour sandrine rousseau yannick
jadot
je vous demande pas pour qui vous êtes
parce que vous êtes obligés en tant que
président du groupe de garder comme ça
votre votre vote pour vous même vos
convictions pour vous même on va on va
parler peut-être ensuite des différences
peut-être philosophique abu dhabi entre
entre les deux camps bien ce que
représentait deux candidats mais il ya
un socle commun
c'est le programme qui a été élaboré au
sein du pôle écologiste du parti europe
ecologie les verts c'est à dire qu'on a
on a deux personnalités avec 2,2 de deux
axes de développement qui sont qui sont
différents deux approches différentes
mais avec de toute façon à un programme
commun cc je peux entendre que c'est ce
soit un petit peu compliqué parce que on
a une habitude à ce que chacun refaites
un dans les élections présidentielles
nous avons toujours eu historiquement
des personnalités qu'ils défendraient
leur propre programme nous nous avons un
programme commun mais nous avons une
façon de 2
une stratégie que ce soit au travers de
ce que développe sandrine rousseau ou
yannick jadot qui est une approche
différente c'est à dire quoi au juste
on voit bien on a une sandrine rousseau
qui est qui et veut absolument
d'ores et déjà faire entendre le fait
qu'il ya vraiment un changement une
transformation à mettre en oeuvre et
elle elle il faut mettre tout de suite
les choses sur la table et puis nous
avons à yannick jadot qui est député
européen qui lui a plutôt l'habitude de
travailler dans le consensus il vise le
même objectif mais lui dit il faut qu'on
avance progressivement il faut qu'on
amène à la transformation et il faut
être avec tous les acteurs pour les
accompagner dans cette dans cette
démarche donc c'est l' approche qui est
qui est différente mais les objectifs
restent les mêmes c'est à dire la sortie
du nucléaire en 2050 qui est un scénario
développé par l'ademe ou négawatt c'est
exactement le même objectif la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments le
travail sur la des mobilités toutes ces
questions là en fait elles sont elles
sont partagées besoin ce n'est pas tout
les tous les candidats mais jet d'eau
par fès par exemple les
délires échos féminisme de l'éco
féministe de sandrine rousseau
sandrine 1 effectivement il faut pas
délirer
sur
le féministe parce que parce que c'est
son cesson son tour qui fait
qu'effectivement c'est une bataille très
fort nous les écologistes nous avons
toujours été fan ou défendre les coûts
féminisme bien sûr d'accord oui oui ça a
toujours fonctionné - on est contre les
discriminations on essaie de faire en
sorte qu effectivement le patriarcat
puce puisse évoluer et nous pensons que
la prédation de l'homme sur la femme
c'est exactement il ya des similitudes
avec la prestation de l'homme sur la
nature donc ils doivent lancer l' ennemi
mais en fait pas du tout bon pas du tout
ce léger à mary j
je vis à vis entouré d'hommes mais par
contre par contre oui j'ai géré on
travaille pour faire en sorte que la
femme ne soit pas cantonné à être chez
elle de ses enfants faire le ménage et
puis on s'occupait mais
jusqu'où enfin c'est à dire que quand
vous promener dans la rue ou dans le
train et qu' il ya des des choses très
naturelle qui se font l'homme qui prend
la place c'est des petites choses un
urbanisme qui ne donne pas la place à la
femme c'est voilà le rôle la place ddd
poussé par exemple quand on était enfin
quand on était parce que je ne sais plus
mais en tant que femme ans il ya des
choses dont la société qui peuvent
évoluer mais ça ne veut pas dire que
bien évidemment on exclut complètement
on n'a pas entendu beaucoup sandrine
rousseau tai chi qui
vous ont fait l'écho s'il veut défendre
la place de la femme est elle a tout à
fait raison là dessus mais vis-à-vis des
femmes voilées et entièrement etc on n'a
pas ce n'est pas l'impression que son
nom soit particulièrement choqués par et
ça me paraît pas être une vision de la
femme alors l'autre l'autre
caractéristique des écologistes c'est
qu'elle nous sommes réellement très
respectueux de la loi 1905 oui et donc
et donc nous avons de vraies valeurs
républicaines et donc pour nous la
laïcité effectivement un rôle incertain
et donc nous pensons que toute personne
a le choix de pouvoir de de pouvoir
exercer sa exercée ou je ne sais pas
comment on dit mais sa religion et que
donc en l'occurrence lorsque l'on est
face à des discriminations lorsqu'on est
face à des femmes qui sont obligées de
bien évidemment on va lutter mais il ya
aussi des femmes qui font le choix de
vivre leur de leur religion et donc
c'est voilà c'est cet équilibre là qu'il
faut qu'il faut trouver tout n'est pas
blanc tout n'est pas noir on le sait et
donc voilà où en tout cas nous sommes
pour pour ses équilibres ses équilibres
et l'éco mobilité pour important de de
l'ecologie plus profondément est ce que
on n'est pas dans le même coupure au
fond que ce qu'est ce qui séparait les
communistes et les sociaux-démocrates se
dire qu il un exode ou serait plutôt
quelqu'un de réformistes qui veut
réformer le système
sandrine rosso ledit des jeux le changer
dit en gros il n'y a pas de dégâts aura
pas de progrès écologique si on ne
change pas le système capitaliste en
gros c'est ça sa thèse mais il faut
changer le système et je suis convaincu
que yannick jadot pense qu'il faut
changer le système on veut pas continuer
à avoir cette
ce développement cette recherche de
croissance perpétuelle
ce set extractives isme 7 exploitons des
exploitations pardon des ressources des
ressources naturelles il va falloir
changer le système mais la façon dont on
va à l'exprimer en fait elle se elle
elle se retrouve ici dans le cadre de la
primaire et ensuite dans la dans la
présidentielle c'est à dire que ce sont
des noces audi il faut d'ores et déjà
immédiatement dire ce qui se passe à ses
dents en 2050 en 2030 en 2050 comment
quelles sont les restrictions qu'est-ce
qu'il faut vraiment où sont les efforts
à faire et yannick jadot lui a une
approche différente il a exactement les
mêmes les mêmes objectifs mais lui dit
travaillons avec les citoyens
travaillons avec les acteurs et faisons
en sorte comme la convention citoyenne
présentons les choses et travaillons
pour que chacun puisse prendre
conscience et du coup agir et je crois
que c'est simplement une une
une fin mais peut-être d'ailleurs je
suis en train d'y penser mais c'est
c'est peut-être aussi l'expression
masculines et féminines c'est à dire que
quand on est confrontés parfois à
prendre des décisions est la femme elle
est tout de suite confronte à la réalité
des choses et elles disent fixons les
choses alors que l'homme va plutôt dire
bon ben voilà comment on va y aller mais
c'est
l'homme plus c'est à dire que doit gérer
plein de choses en même temps qu'elle
il faut
saluer là dessus sur la différence entre
plus sandrine qui paraît radical et à
yannick jadot qui paraît plus
réformistes c'est vrai que je connais
pas forcément tous les programmes en
détail et j'ai pas suivi non plus tous
leurs interviews mais a priori je pense
qu'un système plus radicale permettrait
de changer le l'action politique plus en
profondeur et du coup aurait plus de
conséquences positives sur le futur
après ça que je ne suis pas intéressé
spécialement à toutes leurs
interventions que je pourrai pas vous
répondre en détail suffit de regarder
sur cette coupure entre les écologistes
alors il ya quand même ce coq comme dj
cela tenait il ya comme le fondamentaux
dont la sortie du nucléaire on va en
parler c'est à dire moi ce qui me frappe
arrêtée au gouvernement ce qui me frappe
actuellement s'ils voulaient c'est qu'on
est les partis politiques sont obligés
d'avoir des marqueurs pour pouvoir être
écouté moi ce qui me gêne et gelé connu
dans sa partie seulement de travail pour
véritablement proposer un plan qui soit
non pas un plan avec un titre et une
date mais une démonstration de pourquoi
un titre et une date etc ça se travaille
je pense qu'il faut absolument le faire
c'était une des phares de merkel du
reste était une physicienne d'en guérir
une approche et un discours très
discursif est de démontrer pourquoi le
proposition et je dirais que quand elle
a pris la décision de reading claire l'a
fait de manière émotionnelle alors pour
les ter entre guillemets pro nucléaires
avant donc vous voyez il ya ça c'est ça
qui me gêne dans les partis tous
confondus que soit écologie les autres
c'est la presse des révolutions plus que
de la raison
c'est le scientifique qui comme s'ils
voulaient c'est qu'on est tous citoyens
soumis à une série d'informations
considérable enfin je veux dire
aujourd'hui auto fois dans son village
on avait accès au canard local
maintenant avec internet et tout on sait
tout sur tout et les gens des gens sont
un peu perdus quand même faut vraiment
les gens sont perdus
les premières du pouvoir dominer le
sujet mondial on parlera tout à l'heure
du nucléaire moi je pense que sur le
nucléaire il faut être radical on
parlera de qualité mais je pense que il
faut que les partis politiques ont le
devoir de pédagogie et d'explication
extrêmement fort à faire ce qui est très
compliqué mais il faut le faire et ça
rend les citoyens responsables au lieu
de les rendre entendu et réactif et
émotionnel voilà c'est juste ma remarque
là dessus vincent couronne sur 7 est-ce
qu'il ya 2 2 font deux philosophies
écolo qui ceux qui s'opposent
sur la radicalité moyens il ya un sujet
c'est sur la question de l'impôt que je
trouve la différence entre yannick jadot
et sandrine rousseau intéressante parce
que sandrine rousseau propose notamment
de l'impôt sur le revenu sur une tranche
d'impôt sur le revenu à 80% sur les plus
hauts revenus ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ça ressemble beaucoup en fait
à la proposition qu'avait fait quel
effet jean luc mélenchon dans sa
campagne en 2017 où ils voulaient l'aude
pardon ou françois hollande
françois va être responsable et que la
grande différence pour moi sandrine
rousseau est bien plus radicale même là
dessus que jean luc mélenchon parce que
elle veut un impôt à 80 % pour les
revenus à partir de la tranche au-delà
d'à peu près 60 mille euros par an alors
que mélenchon propose et 90% au-delà de
400 mille euros 1 des revenus de 400000
euros françois hollande c'est 75%
au-delà de 1 million de wii le revenu
donc là là pour sandrine rousseau on est
vraiment sur un impôt qui serait là le
conseil constitutionnel avait déjà dit
pour françois hollande la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme l'a
déjà dit aussi qu'ils seraient
clairement confiscatoire et donc là on
est vraiment dans une position une
proposition qui est extrêmement radical
par rapport à ce qu'ils rapportent même
à charles duke mélenchon qui passe du
coup pour un modèle mais moi une
question quand même imposé à vienne
sonner ghislaine sonepar doux quand elle
parle des co féminisme
et l'écoféminisme je comprends bien en
fait cette idée sur laquelle on
considère que dans l'histoire les hommes
qui ont mené le monde ont mené de monde
par un système d'oppression
colonialiste capitaliste c'est pourquoi
pas ok à la limite mais est-ce que
l'écoféminisme aujourd'hui est pas
complètement dépassés espagne quelque
chose qui en fait une pensée du tue pas
c'est tout simplement parce que vous
donnez l'exemple tout à l'heure de il
n'y a pas de place pour que les femmes
puissent pousser leur possède dans la
rue mais les hommes aussi ils poussent
leurs possède pour tes poussé dans la
rue aujourd'hui que danois de chez moi
il ya une crèche une école maternelle et
le matin il ya autant d'hommes que de
femmes qui poussent les poussettes et en
fait la question que je me pose et que
j'ai envie de vous poser c'est est-ce
que l'écoféminisme n'est pas en fait une
n'est pas en fait regarder le présent à
travers l'une est de passer alors qu'en
fait l'avenir est à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes
une bonne question c'est l'excellente
relation et je crois que effectivement
aujourd'hui si ma foi dans l'espace
public un petit peu plus de place pour
les poussins c'est parce que justement
un jour un homme a commencé à ont poussé
une et que et que les choses ont évolué
dans cette danse est dans ce sens là
mais par exemple typiquement le dosage
des médicaments enfin je je je je quand
on regarde les études en fait elles sont
historiquement ça a été pour pour
l'homme mois ya un certain poids etc et
c'est après qu'on développe d'aider des
doses qu'ils sont et pour les femmes et
pour un pour les enfants maintenant
systématiquement l'intègre mais
historiquement le faisait pas donc il ya
encore plein de combat sur lequel il
faut il faut encore avancé et
heureusement effectivement il est vrai
qu'on arrive à une société qui est
beaucoup plus égalitaire mais on n'y est
pas encore complètement donc
l'écoféminisme nom n'est pas n'est pas
un combat d'arrière garde il faut il
faut continuer à maintenir la pression
mais comme les écologistes ont continué
à mettre la pression sur un sur sur les
enjeux climatiques et le réchauffement
climatique depuis depuis maintenant 40
ans le triptyque de centre et dorsaux
s'éprendre utiliser jeter un qu'elle
applique aux ressources naturelles mais
aussi aux corps des femmes mais aussi
encore des immigrés etc un mot après on
va passer au nucléaire un mot quand même
sur la décroissance qui était la grande
poste 202 delphine batho pendant la
primaire mais qui reprises par son
gendre ou sow ça veut dire quoi les
croissants cesc parce qu on dise c'est
des théoriciens de l'écologie que la
décroissance ça voudrait dire la
division du pouvoir d'achat par trois
la décroissance
chez les jaunes ils sont sortis pour
monson
ça va dépendre aussi 20 finalement c'est
du niveau de vie auquel on souhaite on
souhaite accéder en fait on a
aujourd'hui on sait des stocks de
ressources que naturelles limitées là on
sait que bientôt on aura plus de stock
c'est à dire que là on nous sommes en
train de taper dans le stock des
générations futures ce qui veut dire que
il faut aujourd'hui qu' on puisse
considérer que nous vivons un niveau de
vie particulièrement en france qui
permet de répondre à tous les besoins
voir aujourd'hui on a des bus du dd des
objets qui ne répond plus à ce que nous
avons en nous fabriquent des besoins
typiquement le débat qu'on a aujourd'hui
sur la 5g est ce qu'on a besoin il y
avait toujours l'exemple frappant du
chirurgien aux états unis qui pouvaient
opérer dans le monde entier finalement
autant former et avoir des chirurgiens
directement dans dans notre dans notre
pays pour pouvoir le faire est ce qu'on
a besoin d'un téléphone qui en 3d
nous permettent de nous diriger ce qu'on
a besoin d'avoir un frigo connectés qui
nous dit ce qu'il ya dedans et ce qu'il
faut commander je ne le pense pas la
décroissance c'est ça c'est à dire
aujourd'hui
soyons très clairs sur les ressources
que nous avons et et voyons jusqu'où
nous pouvons aller c'est à dire que
d'être toujours systématiquement dans le
progrès de toujours c'est on est sur la
suractivité c'est
hopkins qui disait
la croissance est bien un enfant qui
grandit c'est très bien mais quand il a
atteint 1 m 80 et qu'il arrive à 1 mètre
90 2 m de maintenance et qui mange
beaucoup plus que ce qu'il ya dans le
foyer à un moment donné ça pose problème
et bannu dans en tout cas dans
l'hémisphère nord on en est là c'est à
dire qu'on consomme beaucoup trop de
ressources naturelles ont dégagé
beaucoup trop de ce2 et que donc il faut
absolument aujourd'hui que nous
puissions arrêter cette course en avant
systématique de la croissance parce qu'
elle ne sert aujourd'hui plus à rien si
ce n'est des puiser d'épuiser le monde
dans lequel nous sommes voilà ce que
c'est pour loin d'accord c'est vrai que
la surconsommation rend pas forcément
plus heureux mais mais mais mais
mercredi décroissance ça veut dire
peut-être aussi moins d'emplois ça veut
dire peut-être plus de chômage
en fait aujourd'hui il ya moins
d'emplois et il ya toujours plus de
chômage
qu'est-ce que vous aussi néanmoins de
recherche - de sciences - de progrès et
que vous vous offusquez qu'on puisse
voir à travers un frigidaire enquête
très bien mais derrière toutes ces
recherches il ya aussi des recherches
sur la méfiance des recherches sur les
mots sur la lutte contre les maladies
etc et donc situer c'est une logique
c'est très amusant c'est très payant de
dire bah est ce qu'on a besoin d'un
téléphone avec un slogan bien sûr que
l'on mais bon ça vous allez convaincre
qu'il d'aider des gens qui sont assez
govou est derrière sens c'est bien qu'il
ya des millions d'autres choses que on
s'en fout le lot g mais la recherche
scientifique c'est extrêmement important
mais bien sûr
et la santé c'est en fait à mon aîné
faut mettre un petit peu d'éthique oui
la santé il faut continuer à faire la
wii l'énergie il faut continuer à faire
de la recherche emploi est ce que nos
informations est ce que dans la
consommation quotidienne vous avez
encore besoin de faire de la recherche
est-ce que vous avez besoin jeudi car il
sait très bien que c'est lui mais je
sens ce sont les mêmes les mêmes
chercheurs les mêmes ingénieurs les
mêmes bien évidemment je n'ai bien sûr
comme le thé dans le civil et le
militaire
c'est un débat philosophique majeur
parce que finalement aujourd'hui on est
confronté à trois grands problèmes vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on est
confrontés au réchauffement climatique
en est confrontée l épuisement des
ressources naturelles et on est
confronté à la pollution et tout ça
c'est lié l'homme aujourd'hui sur cette
terre il a quand même des problèmes
sérieux et c'est pour ça qu'il est très
angoissé 1 une bonne partie des ide les
gens prennent conscience de sa tiers
l'humanité puisque l'humanité la terre
entière les animaux les plantes sont
menacées aujourd'hui par ce qu'on
appelle l'anthropocène c'est à dire
l'action de l'homme dans ces camps mais
philosophiquement compliqué donc je
comprends qu'on réagisse surtout ça et
mais le ciel nous tombe stade moi je
t'ai xk astérix et goscinny avez raison
le ciel nous tombait dans la tête hein
il a donc c'est isabelle et j'avais
raison l'avenir de l'homme puisqu'il
était quand je dis j'ai du mal à
répondre et à ses enfants que j'aime
bien observer ce que disait hashtag dit
un problème sans solution c'est un
problème qui est mal posée posant bien
un problème qu'on impose on vient pour
la il est compliqué mais raison la
recherche c'est que c'est le moteur de
l'homme c'est ce qui c'est ce qui le
motive tous les matins à se lever parce
que parce qu'il veut toujours plus mais
mais ça a des conséquences sur les
ressources avec donc je ne veux pas
trancher le débat enfin il est compliqué
c'est pour ça que les dirigeants ont une
responsabilité absolument considérable
et l'europe en particulier peut-être
seule pose sur cette planète faire
quelque chose par rapport qu'elle que
food au crack convoi et je n'aurais
personnes c'est vrai que oui l'europe un
rôle après on n'en parlera pas ce que
certains disent aussi on peut on peut
faire tous les efforts qu'on veut en
france mais c'est pas l'épaisseur du
trait c'est un pur sang non venez mais
1% de des effets des gaz à effet de
serre donc même si on se priver tous
deux voitures de transport etc ça ne
changerait rien à la figure du monde
mais cet argument qu'on entend un oui
mais bien sûr l'enfant trouvera mais
c'est l'aimer et demi sur fond noir en
fait c'est tous les pays industrialisés
aujourd'hui qu'ils doivent effectivement
faire des efforts mais quel sens on
donne en fait à tout ça enfin moi je
pense que ça d'une manière enfin on on
vit pourquoi pour pour transmettre pour
pour effectivement certainement
s'émanciper s'épanouir mais mais quelle
est la limite on est on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on nous sommes obligés de
nous fixer mois mama pas mon moteur
c'est c'est faire en sorte que mes
enfants peut-être mes petits enfants en
tout cas j'espère puissent vivre dans un
monde viable et tout le monde devrait
partager cette sa fin je veux dire
comment aujourd'hui on a des jeunes
généralement salomé
décroissant je trouve ça
particulièrement intéressant les
recherches qui ont été faits sur la
décroissance d'un point de vue
économique parce qu'on voit bien que
notre système économique actuel il est
plus soutenable et un moment en fait la
décroissance va nous est imposée par le
manque de ressources pour alimenter ce
système économique donc ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant et c'est
notamment abordé dans plusieurs enfin
dans l'est les interviews de yannick
jadot de sandrine rousseau c'est cet
aspect économique de la décroissance il
faut mieux qu'on prenne le problème à la
source et qu'on le règle selon notre
manière avec plusieurs possibilités
plutôt qu'on se retrouve face aux
problèmes dans 20 ans et qu'on se
retrouve un peu imposé sa bulle d'être
manière de régler ce problème c'est
particulièrement intéressant notamment
sur la décroissance économique bien sûr
vincent couronne
oui je sais pas si on peut vendre aux
européens aux français il ya ce que l'on
va on va décroître on va faire décroître
de pib c'est quand même compliqué
politiquement à rendre et on sait bien
que même en politique c'est
essentiellement le court terme qui
l'emportent sert alors
comment est ce qu'on fait la question de
la croissance est ce calcul c'est le pib
par rapport aussi une notion économique
donc c'est le pib donc la question c'est
à voir comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
éventuellement modifier la façon dont on
calcule de pib pour arriver à peut-être
une décroissance économique je ne sais
pas mais qui n'apparaissent pas comme
une décroissance du pib
par exemple est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
introduire dans le pib la question de la
de la protection de la biodiversité
c'est à dire que si on diminue la
biodiversité dans un en europe ça fait
diminuer le pib en fait diminué ce qui
fait que du coup on serait obligé en
fait de protéger la biodiversité
protéger le climat pour avoir un pib qui
est en croissance
ce que c'est quand même une dose sur
économique un aussi le
dérèglement climatique
chaque année ils coûtent à ce jour 1 le
dérèglement climatique 1700 milliards
d'euros en vendant en 2075 il devrait
coûter à peu près trente mille milliards
d'euros par an le dérèglement climatique
ça c'est le presque consensus des
économistes qu'on a en 2025 sur la
question donc c'est énorme donc en fait
pourquoi pas de beaucoup pourquoi pas
inclus enfin diront pib le calcul se
calculant et donc du coup au lieu
d'avoir une décroissance de l'économie
on aurait une croissance en fait deux et
notre bien-être
économique et environnemental etc et
bons voilà comment est ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse de pib aujourd'hui ce calcul
le son calcul est fixé par une loi
européenne qui a été adoptée en 2013 et
il n'avait déjà une auparavant
et donc c'est parlement européen il
conseille clairement qu'ils vont décider
de comment est-ce qu'on calcule de mal
pib donc c'est sûr le parlement européen
et le conseil de l'union européenne
qu'il faut qu'il faut agir je rappelle
qu'en 2013 le parlement européen le
conseil ont ajouté dans le calcul du pib
la prise en compte du trafic de drogue
et de la prostitution comme quoi dans
pib on lui met plein de choses mais un
peu
après cas il ya aussi d'autres courants
écologistes pour ça alors qu'ils sont
moins connus comme l'écho modernisme
notamment d'ordre
c'est plutôt luc ferry qui l'ont en
effet le papa aulas peut en france qui
considère la croissance et l'écologie 1
mais c'est pas vrai attendez je crois si
on a besoin de se rassurer derrière un
pib qui continue de croître mais qu'on
modifie saison lemay
deux problèmes que nous avons
aujourd'hui des décisions à prendre pour
que notre monde restait bien alors on va
passer au deuxième thème qui est
essentiel de cette émission c'est
peut-on sortir du nucléaire alors appuyé
comme ça
[Musique]
peut-on vraiment sortir du nucléaire
alors vous ne l'avez rappelé la sortie
du nucléaire pour les écologistes c'est
pourquoi il faut sortir de là pourquoi
il faut sortir du nucléaire parce qu'on
a enfin différents
bonnes raisons 1 la question des déchets
qui est qui a toujours prévalu 2 il y à
la question de l'uranium de la ressource
nous ont depuis 2001 à plus de mines et
donc on est très dépendant d'autres
d'autres pays on a également la question
du dérèglement climatique qui fait que
nous avons aujourd'hui des des centrales
vieillissantes dans le clair on peut pas
on peut pas du coup faire la rénovation
et faire du neuf avec du vieux fin quand
on voit le dérapage de des eps on voit
bien que les centrales nucléaires que
nous avons aujourd'hui qui ont entre 30
40 enfin la dernière je prends a été
fait dans les années dans les années
2000 enfin les plus anciennes en tout
cas aujourd'hui n'ont plus la capacité
de pouvoir se se moderniser et en tout
cas ce m ce maître pas et puis la
dernière raison qui moi me semble
importante c'est que en france le
nucléaire a vraiment freiner la
transition énergétique à brno freiné par
le lobbying en fait le le développement
des énergies des énergies renouvelables
et ça ça pose réellement
un sujet c'est pour ça que nous pensons
qu'il ya réellement besoin de faire une
une transition avec avec le scénario
négawatt qui certes fait monter les
aînés et les énergies renouvelables mais
surtout qui fait aussi décroître la
consommation énergétique c'est pas juste
un marqueur politique c'est des épaules
olé
il ya toujours des mythes dans des dons
dépassent tout calcul notre noter
enfin on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'urgence climatique et l'accélération
des émissions du co2 a fait en sorte
qu'on a pris même quand même il me
semble conscience sur le fait
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on travaille
beaucoup plus sûr sûr sûr la transition
il faut qu'on arrive en tout cas en
france nous aimerions bien avoir une
mixité énergétique qui nous permette
effectivement à 2050 et réduction des
énergies à pouvoir faire cesser ces
centrales qui sont aujourd'hui
dangereuse qui qui qui font que on a
enfin fessenheim c'est c'est aujourd'hui
on a des piscines remplies de
combustible qui va falloir au fur et à
mesure traiter confiné m mettre dans un
coin c'est 40 ans de démantèlement c'est
2040 en bas on est en 2020 ça fait vingt
ans donc 2040 pour démonter une une
centrale une centrale nucléaire et donc
semafo qu'il faut que l'on commence pour
nous parce que c'est très long bien sûr
c'est très très long c'est très très bon
et là et toujours ce donjon ya des
écologistes qui ont pour la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique comme jean
marc jancovici notamment qui sont très
pro nucléaire qui dit on peut pas se
passer d'une éclaire sa soeurette unis
c'est aussi une lituanie borg à votre
votre thèse
c'est un des barons la vie faut prendre
d'abord son côté scientifique et tout ça
procède au fond d'une équation que
j'achetais n'a trouvé en
1905 c'est une année miraculeuse pour la
physique dix ont acheté quatre
publications qui pouvait donner quatre
prix nobel faut quand même excellent et
sa fameuse équation se régaler de ces
deux c'est à dire que les gars les
pseudos ça veut dire quoi ça va être
toute variation de la masse de l'atome
donc dans ce noyau en particulier
entraîne une variation d'énergie et ça
veut dire quoi concrètement pour nous ça
veut dire qu'un gramme d'uranium 235
kiffis yonne c'est équivalent à deux
millions deux millions de grammes de
pétrole 3 millions de grammes de charbon
ça veut dire que la loi de la physique
d'un nature nous offre une loi
extraordinaire qui est le nucléaire
c'est qu'il doit écraser je vous
rappelle que quand même l'essentiel de
l'énergie qui vient sur terre est
d'origine nucléaire le soleil c'est un
immense et acteur thermonucléaire une
immense atelier vous connaissez les
conséquences du soleil la géothermie
c'est la radioactivité de la terre c'est
donc on voit que c'est une loi qui nous
est donnée par la physique on peut faire
abstraction cette loi mais c'est quand
même une loi qui dit kéké extraordinaire
alors le péché originel du nucléaire
c'est quoi finalement c'est hiroshima
même même einstein reyes et le team
astel et même effrayé débat parce qu'on
en faisait ça c'est une c'est une vérité
génération militari au lait voilà même
et se dire que le nucléaire
c'est de mauvais parce que y ait eu
régime parce qu'il faut le schéma s'est
fait impression de quoi s'est fait
abstraction des 50 milliards de tonnes
qu'on aimait de co2 chaque année ça
c'est des déchets pour moi monstrueux on
voit les conséquences aujourd'hui
nucléaire n'émet pas de co2 un hommage
que je veux dire c'est que toute action
physique industriels etc procède de des
déchets créé des déchets etc il n'existe
pas donc ça veut dire on parle des
déchets radioctifs vous dites voilà donc
le déchet tablette moi je pense que
c'est exactement le contraire les
d'immenses avantages déchets nucléaires
c'est qu'ils sont en masse peu nombreux
65 mille tonnes de combustible par an
par rapport aux 45 milliards de tonnes
de co2 c'est quand même rien du tout
c'est un million de fois moins
deuxièmement ils sont hyper 3 sable et
troisièmement la france qui est de ce
point de vue là était un exemple a fait
un plan de gestion des déchets
nucléaires qui fait qu'on sait
exactement où mission comme ambition de
settat meinau faussement uns que les
autres activités industrielles on s'en
fout il n'y a pas de ya pas de suivi
alors que on est pollué on est fâché
c'est absolument pour moi hyper
paradoxal se dissout discours sur le
déchet pour moi c'est un non problème
absolue hier après une technique vous le
faire admettre par les populations mais
par rapport à ce qu'on est en train de
faire ce poison lent du co2 pour moi
c'est un problème beaucoup plus simple
de dire si j'ajoute que le ciel nous est
déjà tombé sur la tête en 1973 se passer
vous souvenez 1913 l'économie mondiale
s'est arrêtée amérique aux bêtes reliait
rebonds comment un régime gouvernement
français pour moi à l'époque a élargi
devenir extrêmement intelligente c'est à
dire qu'il a réagi en faisant une
véritable filière nucléaire comme on dit
de la mine jusqu'en l'enrichissement les
centrales et puis le retraitement
derrière et les déchets il il a fait
quelque chose qui est admiré dans le
monde entier nous on est là à dire
sessegnon lui tf1 pour moi c'est alors
bien sûr qu'ils aient des risques moi je
trouve que j'étais exploitants
nucléaires donc j'ai connu c est l
autorité de sûreté nucléaire en france
et si vous voulez en france on peut être
fier de cette autorité indépendante je
dis moi la chaussure ont dégagé à
fukushima l'ong à fukushima et puis
l'accident de tchernobyl ce sont deux
accidents qui sont liées à l'absence
d'autorités de sûreté nucléaire
indépendantes c'est à dire ces deux
problème démocratique majeur
entre tepco au japon et le gouvernement
il veut une collusion qui était
inacceptable qu'en france vous dire moi
j'ai suivi d'effets rude de l'autorité
de son d'une guerre elle est vraiment
indépendante et elle est très dure d'où
les augmentations de prix que vous
mentionnez très justement d'ailleurs
mais on ne peut pas s'en passer je
deviens franchement je pense qu'on peut
pas s'en passer alors vous avez raison
c'est transitoire le on à l'uranium
c'est vrai c'est clair c'est ses limites
et ça nous fait quelques centaines
d'années et puis derrière on te le moyen
le plus tenir bon ça pose tout ça pose
des problèmes jeudi passé impose pas
fini mais on a des solutions
transitoires jean claude rich et raisons
ont probablement que la science et la
technologie veineuse d être d'autres
solutions c'est vrai mais aux jouets pas
comment on peut se passer du nucléaire
donc transitoirement l'emprise une
baisse des autres ressources alors j'ai
dit que je vends une éolienne c'est à
peu près mille tonnes de matériel il
faut 3 millions viennent pour faire
l'équivalent en masse d'énergie d'une
centrale nucléaire mais ça veut dire 3
millions ça veut dire 3 millions de
tonnes de matériaux qu'il faut trouver
donc ton trop prime des ressources
naturelles si l on prend beaucoup moins
de place avec une centrale nucléaire
qu'avec trois mille éoliennes vrai c'est
toute une série de problèmes c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure il faut
bien poser le problème dans sa globalité
ce qui est compliqué je suis d'accord
avec vous c'est très compliqué il faut
le poser tel que c'est très émotionnel
cette histoire nucléaire c'est pour ça
que c'est très
fraîche et originale de rhj hymne à la
physique doit d une loi extraordinaire
si on n'utilise pas bon je dis on est
fou oui c'est vrai qu'elle est bon c'est
vrai que les accidents qui peuvent qui
peuvent en effet impressionné les
opinions et est ce que je sais mais
est-ce que les énergies
de remplacement du nucléaire sont assez
fortes pour nous permettre justement
d'être même un développement icos je
pense par exemple recharger les
batteries électriques quoi est ce qu'on
pourra se passer du nucléaire y arriver
ne pourra se passer du nucléaire que si
effectivement on diminue notre
consommation énergétique enfin très
concrètement il revient sur sur le sujet
de la décroissance et sur la façon dont
nous gérons dont nous gérons nos vies et
c'est pour ça que je reparle de la 5g
mai mais en fait nous avons aujourd'hui
une économie une industrie nucléaire qui
pousse à toujours consommer plus puisque
effectivement ça permet de justifier le
fait qu'il va falloir démanteler les
anciennes centrales pour pouvoir
reconstruire des nouvelles aujourd'hui
dans la construction des nouvelles on
n'est pas encore tout à fait tout à fait
decker et on a des dérapages 17 millions
10,7 milliards un nom sur sur sur
flamanville qui démontre encore
aujourd'hui qu'on n'a pas manifestement
les capacités de pouvoir inventer une
nouvelle génération
donc donc il faut à mon sens là encore
moins moi je positionne toujours sa
sueur sur la question de l'éthique en
fait moi je trouve que c'est un beau
d'ailleurs dont on utilise très peu
aujourd'hui mais qu'est ce que l'on veut
pour le devenir de de nos enfants est ce
que l'on veut un monde où l'on consomme
toujours plus et donc sur lequel on a
besoin aujourd'hui de l'énergie
nucléaire pour pouvoir avoir une vie je
ne sais pas laquelle ils feront ils
auront plus tard mais mais il faut bien
là encore à partir du moment où on a des
limites à partir du moment où on
considère que la santé que le risque
industriel est un enjeu majeur est bien
à partir de laquelle décision prenons
nous pour faire en sorte que les
générations futures puissent vivre
correctement
dans ce monde en fait c'est cissé pour
si on arrive à un monde va faire en
sorte que le nucléaire que danger qu'on
pressent parfois d'uniterre n'existe
plus et angers sco préférant est ce que
là vous n'êtes plus dans une position
plus vidéo logique que réaliste le
risque zéro n'existe pas de syriens la
sûreté nucléaire en france j'ai aucun
sujet là dessus vous avez entièrement
raison et donc dans le monde ce n'est
absolument pas le cas et que donc on
peut toujours enfin je pense qu'on n'a
vraiment une exception française sur sur
sur le sujet parce qu'on a été
réellement moteur là dessus mais mais
mais autour ce n'est aujourd'hui
absolument pas le cas il ya énormément
de questions qui se posent on n'a pas
encore réglé le problème de fukushima et
s'il devait y avoir encore un accident
clair comment comment allons-nous de
gérer et et la question finale c'est la
santé la question finale c'est la
question de la santé des générations des
générations futures donc donc quitte à
revoir le modèle et c'est l'objectif que
nous nous fixions dès 2022 pour les
présidentielles et bien revoyons le et
alors et la radicalité c'est quoi c'est
traiter le problème à la racine nous il
nous semble
prioritaire de faire en sorte que les
générations futures puissent vivre en
bonne santé dans un monde viable donc
donc voilà comment remettons-nous en
cause tout ce que nous avons pu mettre
et développer un aujourd'hui pour est
bon pour qu' on puisse avoir une vie
digne
ces gaz et âme est plus apaisée et oui
moins violente car on voit bien qu'on
n'est pas dans une société on fait
affaire on parle encore du pipe de la
croissance etc mais on voit bien que
c'est pas un modèle de société dans
lequel on s'épanouit quand aujourd'hui
des
[Musique]
de l'e10 ça dépend du choix de la
société qu'on veut faire admettre à
leurs ports français aujourd'hui qu'on
va faire une décroissance est possible
je veux dire les amis juifs très bien
ils n'ont pas la science et des
technologies qu'on a mais ils vivent des
amis chiens c'est très possible le
problème c'est qu'il faut que les partis
politiques arrivent à amener les gens à
une forme de croissance différent je
pense que notre ami couronne a tout à
fait raison il faut vraiment une
définition du pipi qui par leur a tout à
fait raison c'est un problème majeur et
c'est un discours politique que les gens
devraient avoir c'est changer la nature
du débat pour sûr plus positif que de
négatif mais mais mais si vous voulez ça
c'est un choix qui doit être politique
qui doit être qui doit être très très
lent enfin qui doivent qui ne peut-être
que l'on donc il faut y aller à dire
j'arrête de nucléaire regardez regardez
l'allemagne l'allemagne qui a une pré
cités qui polit dix fois brillé jusque
là la magie pour les bleus ce maudit où
il exerçait et deux à chaque doigt
d'électricité en plus il ya un problème
de fond donc ça ne peut être que
transitoire c'est là l'exemple de
l'allemagne il sonnait vous avez tout à
fait raison le nucléaire a retardé les
énergies renouvelables ça c'est un
élément objectif c'est dire 115
constants tcc nucléaire c'est évidemment
aberrant problème c'est d'aller
doucement bien vers 50 voire même moins
c'est 4% le monde a le nucléaire c'est
rien du tout donc c'est faux ferme mais
je pense qu'il ya une solution on vous
avait dit que la france les états unis
quand même le point de salut ni c'est
que c'est privé alors investir dans le
nucléaire prix privé c'est compliqué
donc ça se fait pas quoi tout simplement
pontaise vous avez vu ce que c'est ce
pas steve jobs et bill gates fait ils
essaient d'investir dans les directs il
ya des solutions même et c'est vrai que
ça prendra du temps à 2050 j'ai du mal
ay croire mais je suis d'accord avec
vous il faut baisser nucléaire en france
et pas photo mais on ne peut pas s'en
passer à mon avis dans le monde dans
l'est pour la maison de la physique pour
les lois de la physique et les années 70
un rapport milloz on sait que le modèle
nous entraîne au mur et depuis soixante
dix nos dirigeants il faut prendre le
temps on peut pas faire aux citoyens
mais sauf que réellement enfin moi je
pense qu'on vit là dans une période
assez clé quand on vois moi je pense
vraiment que la convention citoyenne
j'ai eu la chance de faire la campagne
des régionales avec annie pts apataki
vraiment était une personne qui vivait
tranquillement sa vie dans le modèle
économique actuel et qui a été et elle
dit c'est une chance il ya eu un tirage
au sort et tout d'un coup on m'a
expliqué et on m'a ouvert les yeux sur
sûr qu est ce qu est l urgence
climatique et à la revue finalement sa
façon et je pense que si on était en
capacité de pouvoir mais tous ensemble
parce que effectivement là la difficulté
c'est quand les écolos 10 ha il faut
être radical et réal haut et que les
eaux du genou on peut continuer à faire
le pis il faut juste intégré un petit
peu il faut qu' il faut à un moment
donné que toute la classe politique
parce que c'est sa responsabilité c'est
son devoir de dire aujourd'hui nous
avons des obligations pour les
générations futures et donc nous devons
aller tous ensemble vers le médecin et
donc il faut arrêter de financer parfois
du progrès je suis réellement pour pour
pour la recherche mais pas par pas
partout pas pour tous il ya des choses
on pourrait vraiment voilà faire en
sorte que les choses se passent ce parce
que et il va falloir le faire de plus en
plus rapidement mais sert avec alcan son
vrai nom rousseau dit on va augmenter
les sens de 6 % chaque année aussi 6
antibruit sentez-vous dans chacun d'eux
faisait beaucoup
ça fait deux fois madame que vous voulez
que les autres partis politiques
devraient se saisir de l'écologie or dès
qu'un parti politique autre que le vôtre
parle d'écologie tout de suite vous et
vos amis jeter l'anathème sur ce parti
politique indien à bisons pas le droit
mais sont pas assez à gauche mais c'est
mais c'est du pipeau c'est pas vrai que
c'est donc vous
vous bloquez vous même la possible votre
parti d'avoir une réflexion
tous les partis ou intéressant est ce
qu'il ya un seul parti qui est encore là
à nier l'évidence nous c'est fini plus
du tout est ce que ma chronique évidence
non est-ce que même anne hidalgo nie
l'évidence et la gauche ou ce qu'il en
reste ni l'évidence non pas du tout non
mais la protection des droits qu'on
appelle la transition écologique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est
probablement pas tout à fait à la
hauteur des enjeux ne vous méprenez pas
ce que nous savons où il faut être
réaliste mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on va pas relancer le débat mais
quand vous dis là se voudrait qu'ils
jouent bien mais il faudrait que les
autres partis politiques sont en parle
dès qu'ils s'en empare vite départ à 12
ans
j'entendais encore sandrine rousseau lot
d'infos que oui mais toutes façons
l'écologie nous peut être que qq qui à
gauche et très à gauche et c'est la
bomba très bien la messe est dite 6
essor l'écologie politique mais c'est ça
s'est tué la veille les gens vont être
un peu car
c'est une écologie pied une écologie
politique et une écologie venir vous
étonnez pas de faire des résultats que
vous faites
ne convaincrez personnes
je pense que la question de la justice
sociale est aussi importante dans dans
le cheminement et dreux et dans la
transformation et dans la transition là
encore on a toujours eu une prédation
des des plus riches sur l'exploitation
des plus faibles et que donc l'écologie
ne peut pas aller sans la justice la
justice sociale et moi j'ai vu je suis
conseiller régional d'opposition de
valérie pécresse elle fait de l'écologie
effectivement la loi allure nous sommes
aujourd'hui amenés à moins consommer des
spas sa désormais habilité etc mais elle
est au pouvoir aujourd'hui enfin elle à
elle à 5 milliards par an pour pouvoir
agir lll elle dissimule on est on est
dans une écologie de petits pas et donc
on ne dit pas on sait pas bien vous
n'avez pas droit de faire de l'écologie
au contraire on demande à ce qu'on en
fasse toujours plus et on met énormément
de pression et énormément de rapport de
force pour que justement les choses les
choses avancent et je pense même que on
a réussi à faire accélérer les choses
mais pas tout seul dans ton parti
politique c'est parce que les
concitoyens et les concitoyens se sont
rendu compte qu'il fallait effectivement
avant de les faire bouger les parties
mais aujourd'hui ceux qui sont au
pouvoir ne vont pas suffisamment loin
parce que il continue à développer un
modèle économique continue à penser
qu'il faut aider total les grosses
entreprises parce que c'est quelqu'un
nous a tellement parce qu'il veut nous
restons très très peu de temps ça
l'avait très bien est ce que vous êtes
prêt tout vous finalement à changer un
peu le mode de vue votre mode de vie
pour voilà la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique notamment oui
exactement et comme on en discutait tous
ensemble c'est vrai que l'on voit bien
que le nucléaire sur le long terme ça
peut pas fonctionner techniquement après
ce qui pourrait être intéressant c'est
aussi de regarder chez lui devant son
lycée saint
charles est plutôt au niveau de la
disponibilité des ressources qui
permettent de faire fonctionner on voit
que c'est un peu limité sur sur la
longue durée ce qui pourrait être
intéressant c'est d'aller regarder chez
nos voisins comment il procède et
notamment au royaume uni ils ont mis en
place un système d'éolien en mer qui est
assez important et assez performant et
voit que nous en france on a des projets
qui se développe notamment manche mais
qui met du temps à ce 2e place qui sont
énormément contesté sur lequel n'y a pas
forcément de consensus politique et sur
lequel l'avancée des projets très
compliqué et je me demande si au fond ce
serait pas un système politique qu'il
faudrait remettre en cause dès la racine
pour permettre dès que des projets sont
votés et dès qu'il ya une volonté de
mise en place pour permettre à ce projet
d'aboutir
techniquement assez rapidement parce
qu'on voit par exemple sur des projets
en manche mer du nord ça fait déjà
quatre cinq ans qu'on en discute il n'y
a aucune éolienne pour l'instant qui est
qui en place et c'est papa qui est des
recours il ya des procédures qui sont un
peu compliquées quand il est comme ça
pas anormal que la population puisse
donner son avis sur un sujet aussi
important que les pêcheurs grassart
droit de regard là-dessus ça me paraît
pas aberrant modèle anglais est un
modèle extrêmement cohérent et il ya une
partie du nucléaire une partie aux
lyrics partie elle est très forte c'est
incroyable d'ailleurs d'investissement
qui font dans le pays nos amis chinois
entre guillemets oui
on s'attend pour le nucléaire c'est
permanence et un point de l'éolien et du
solaire c'est que c'est transitoire
c'est sa faiblesse nucléaire ces
permanences avait pas être ça mais pas
de co2 et il ya quand même un peu de
ressources plusieurs siècles quand même
hein donc non le modèle anglais est un
modèle très équilibré et pas du tout
anti nucléaire
menace pirée au niveau des yeux ben moi
je suis pour le bouddhisme
que les décrets contestés
à l'est derrière moi de 20 cents en non
je vous dis hein mais juste un bout sur
cette question oui juste à votation j'ai
pas grand chose à dire je crois sur ce
sujet parce que moi en tant que juriste
je sais pas si j'ai forcément quelques
jeunes à leur passage
j'ai juste une dernière question à vous
poser ou celle là si vous aviez alors
allez taxer la troisième partie est
aussi alors est-ce que vous avez regardé
de débats et bourg
mélenchon
est ce que voilà c'est un problème
l'audience elle a fait quatre fois plus
ils ont fait quoi deux fois plus que
valérie pécresse qui était sur france 2
c est ce que c'est pas un problème quand
même le souvenir ces débats la foire
d'empoigné qui vous parliez de la réseau
total air et un livre qu'il faut
absolument lire ce livre s'appelle cette
défiance été fait par deux économistes
qui montre la défiance que la france en
partie par rapport aux autres pays
européens 1 par rapport à sa classe
politique ça c'est un problème majeur
c'est un problème et
oui on avait on avait on a vu il y avait
des enquêtes y laisser le gouvernement
français était le plus déconsidérés
corporatisme concert à 10 sont les deux
problèmes dans le livre souligné
observant et finalement les gens ils
écoutent zemmour parce que quelques pas
à 10 par rapport à 106 défiance est ce
qu'il n'est pas l'homme qui peut entrer
le musée on va je mettais en plus il a
un discours très discursif y démontre ce
qu'ils me disent y pratiquer si oui moi
je vais pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il
dit mais mais au moins il essaye de
démontrer la viande et moi je n'ai pas
écouté le débat donc je suis essai
d'albacete paristech était tout sauf une
foire d'empoigné
c'était non pas un débat on a tous cru
qu'ils allaient s'écharper et c'est pas
du tout c'était sécuriserait tous les
deux intérêt de les bateaux donc
que je parte pas aucun des deux donne
dans mon cas mais les des gens qui
avaient un petit peu réfléchi calmement
la mode de culture ce soit mélenchon
comme zemmour on avait enfin
l'impression qu'ils avaient d'aider des
gens qui avaient un petit peu lu
quelques livres avant d'arriver à la
télévision la nôtre 10 secondes parce
qu'il faut qu'on ait
des débats c'était un débat quand même
comment dire assez posé je suis assez
d'accord avec jean charles là dessus en
revanche quand je trouve que le
constraste le contraste avec l'allemagne
est assez saisissant ou en allemagne à
une campagne s'est faite beaucoup au
centre alors qu'en france ça se fait de
plus en plus aux extrêmes les
expérimentés qui a vendu à nos
différences de modèles qu'en france il y
avait en personne voilà on va devenir
une personne qui va en fait être seul
pouvoir alors qu en allemagne on va dire
une personne qui va devoir faire des
compromis avec les autres partis
merci beaucoup merci à tous 20 secondes
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
parler de politique et de religion
propos de la parution du livre dès
juillet merci beaucoup je sais je mais
vers sigean servent rajeuni merci
beaucoup salomé trélut et bercy beaucoup
guy turcotte beauregard et à très vite
pour un nouveau numéro de paf donc
politique et religion
[Musique]